drunk tank pink is a shade of pink paint
that psychologists used to use to paint
the inside of jail cells and in the
1960s a group of psychologists went
around schools in Canada and they try to
find a color of paint that would pacify
the aggressive students or the badly
behaved students and it would also
improve their engagement in class so
they went and painted these these school
halls and these these walls inside the
school classrooms a whole lot of
different colors sometimes they painted
them pink sometimes blue sometimes
yellow sometimes green they had theories
about which colors would work best and
ultimately they found according to their
results that pink was the best color it
had the greatest tendency to lead people
to be karma the students were more
engaged and so they wanted to do more
work with this if pink could do that to
students in the classroom they started
to wonder whether it might also be
useful in the prison system and a couple
of naval officers who were at a prison
in Seattle said that they wanted to try
this so what they decided to do is to
bring this pink paint to their prison
and to paint the inside of one of the
jail cells bright pink and so since
people were calling jail cells drunk
tanks they called a drunk tank pink and
what they found was that the prisoners
they put in there these were the worst
prisoners the most dangerous and the
most aggressive prisoners when they were
badly behaved they would put them inside
this this drunk tank pink cell for about
15 minutes and what they reported was
that over a nine-month period there
wasn't a single aggressive or violent
incident and this gained a lot of
currency people were very curious about
it about its other applications football
coaches from from Division one schools
started to wonder whether they could
paint the visiting locker rooms the same
color to pacify their opponents no one
had any idea that pink would have such a
striking effect on behavior there are a
number of different explanations for the
effect which is true of many of the
effects that I talked about in the book
it could be because we associate pink
with perhaps femininity and therefore
these aggressive males tended to be a
little bit more reserved
it could be something about this color
and how it interacts with our physiology
and that's one of the arguments that the
founder of the color the guy who named
the color makes he suggests that there
is something about the way this color
hits our eyes and interacts with our
brains that leads us to become I'm not
sure that I buy that 100%
I think the the better explanation is
probably about our expectations and our
associations when we see the color pink
but that complexity I think is present
in a lot of the examples in the book